ganz ehrlich es ist schon jetzt wenig
sinnvoll metern mit der wunde muss
klarer und nicht gold und muss die
wechsel muss dusche muss aber andere
macht anderen kindern aber minderheit
muss man einmal waschen putzen machen
und so seehofer und ich habe das ja wo
ist eigentlich muss man lernen und
klüger und heike und das kind macht
eigentlich zum anfang doch glücklich
also chronische chance
die chronische krankheit heißt colitis
ulcerosa das sorgenkind von robin
rehmann ist sein darf
[Musik]
robin rehmann das ist der mann bei sr
virus der psychisch und chronisch
kranken menschen mit seiner radiosendung
sick of silence eine stimme gibt
und morgen mit zu tun dass er selber
leidet seit sieben jahren an einer
autoimmunerkrankung sein ganzes leben
dreht sich und seinen chronisch
entzündeten dickdarm
doch das soll sich ändern im juli 2018
fällt er die bisher wichtigste
entscheidung seines lebens und hält
diese in einem video fest
noch am 24 total recall economy.de haben
wir ganz einfach wird es nicht das wesen
der kooperation
wer es liebt mich
diese beschäftigen
münchen
und dass ich fertig war und einen druck
wie sich mediziner entwickelt
und ich bin nicht so gut ist
[Musik]
so erschöpft sie und kaputt und buchwert
die offen
wünscht mir glück
die entfernung des dickdarms soll wieder
normalität in sein leben bringen so tut
prof
von nun an begleitet ich meinen
arbeitskollegin ruppin mit der kamera
zwei jahre lang von risiken und
lebensqualität von schmerz und glück
davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
das video in dem er seinen entscheid
bekannt gibt sehen tausende mit seinem
colitis ulcerosa flock lässt er die welt
an seinem leben und seiner
krankheitsgeschichte teilhaben
dann sehr viel kommentar auf twitter
verfremden und verändere das sind über
100 dass gott der mit drohung mich
irgendwie in szene setzte sondern es
geht darum der chronisch kranke menschen
sehr viel der folge der schweiz des
gesichts und sei über die situation der
stadt wie man sich fühlt und sind
gefühlte größe steige das video social
media normal wir wie sich gegenteilig
machte zeigt man muss klar und streiche
und ich bin happy und alles schön und
gut und mini art von social media wie
tragischer erste kleine schwäche zeigt
und innere zerrissenheit um den kampf
und ich glaube dass sich damit viel
kritisierte aber dass sie erst vor sich
tatsächlich leiden in der schweiz mehr
als zwei millionen menschen an einer
lang andauernden krankheit die nicht
vollständig geheilt werden kann
bei robin finales 2012 an der fernseh
und radiomoderator war anfang 30 ein
workaholic
einer der den exzess liebte und für
jeden zu haben war nach einem konzert
mit seiner punkband hat er erstmals
dieser schrecklichen bauchkrämpfe und
schwierige stuhlgang schön dass man auf
youtube und jetzt gerade
wie sieht das leben anders als bei einer
magen-darm-grippe hörten durchfall und
krämpfe nie mehr auf darmblutungen kamen
hinzu bis zu 30 stuhl gänge am tag auch
unkontrollierte ein albtraum ein
unbeschwertes leben als partymacher und
entertainer war plötzlich vorbei robin
zog sich immer mehr zurück
zwar häufig allein und verbrachte die
tage auf dem sofa und der toilette
es drehte sich alles um die krankheit
mögliche ursachen um die
symptombekämpfung um medikamente und
alternative heilmethoden
ich meine man sich schon mal ausprobiert
haben doch alles gemacht für ihn also
für hypnose drachenblut und darum klar
dass es eine komische versucht seine
rote oder so dass man das eine geschickt
oder nur noch wirklich super
entspannungstherapie er mache ich dann
natürlich alles harvey ka news acryl
oder meditation und so und alle die
sache hinten sind sie sich nicht falsch
der shop ist es heilt einfach nicht die
schwere chronische unheilbar kranken und
sich dann plötzlich am 6 ich bin bald
standen spiel geguckt und das wiso und
geist nichts kostet die kommune das ist
für mich ganz klar ist jedoch habe dann
habe ich das alles im vagen etwa gleitet
und mittlerweile haben die strafe nicht
sagt extrem niedrig sei mein job ist
schön wenn das richtig gut und man weiß
dass gott glaube jemand wird klar machen
weil er unsicher ist redet er in der
zeit vor der operation mit leuten die
bereits eine dickdarm entfernung hinter
sich haben
natürlich mache ich jetzt schon wie es
besser geht und sich positiv das gibt
mir sicherheit für die in der
entscheidung nicht haben
logistik fia lied wo es gegen solcherlei
de kontakt zu erfahren wo der operation
gemacht hat und seitdem stand das macht
er natürlich längst und das sind 20
prozent weniger verdienen
die operation machen wir davon reden
dass es ihnen besser geht nachher die
zahl 20 prozent lässt hobby nicht mehr
los
bei einer von fünf personen geht bei der
operation etwas schief oder breitet sich
die chronische entzündung danach an
anderer stelle aus vier wochen vor der
op begleitet robin zu einer endoskopie
im universitätsspital zürich wird sein
dickdarm ein letztes mal untersucht
[Musik]
guten morgen und die magie schon gedacht
dass ich wirklich noch mal findet im rat
unter letzte heute 20 bis 30 zentimeter
boxsets eigentums aber unrecht schweren
zu rechnen sei ja eigentlich ein
gesunder baum war ja eigentlich muss
eine titanen 2 bei der colitis ulcerosa
wenn man da auch noch ein
teilunternehmen hund ganz schlacht ja
was wir sagen ob 11 und augen sondern
immer die linke sieht dass ich den
kunden anderer teil häufig entzündet
unser heftiger noch ein
was ich nicht gestand ist die letzte 30
zentimetern entsprechend sind das
verstanden dieses trios war entzündet
und das bringt mich in den griff aber
dickdarm- ist zwei meter lang und novell
30 zentimeter entzündet sind waren sie
ganz dick da muss also rein national
begriff ich das noch nie ausgesehen als
seien sie wies zweifel an der operation
werden immer größer ein paar tage später
im selben spital
alle sechs wochen kriegt er eine
infusion immunsuppressiva damit können
schüler zwar hinausgezögert werden
doch heftige nebenwirkungen sind die
folge wenn ist also auch die kooperation
macht also mir ist jetzt machen reicht
dafür ein schlosser prominenter
verschließt und ich glaube nicht der
termin absagte 27 tagesschau die
operation schreiben das ab sagt dann
mach ich's nicht mache die operation
wirklich mir sondern krampf und kampf
vielleicht nur jahre wieder so und b
jahre geschwächt und für bass als
energetisch lange und so passt es locker
und wenn ich mach uns hilft gott dann
fürs auge diese aber nur was ist das für
ein entscheid gar nicht treffen sich
unmöglich ich habe entscheidende treffer
und wenn ich mich entscheide mich nichts
entscheiden denn passiert ja einfach
nicht und ich biete jedem stage-x game
wie will riskiert dafür dass er
vielleicht besser aber es klang so
gemacht welcher luftballon so
[Musik]
der entscheid wird dadurch erschwert
dass sich robin ganz plötzlich besser
fühlt psychisch aber auch körperlich ein
gespräch mit seinem arzt soll klarheit
schaffen und wie sich herausstellt weiß
dass also der endoskopie in dieselbe
richtung wie robbins gefühl ich muss
jetzt ehrlich sagen so wie es ihnen
ebenfalls 6 8 wochen gegen wo sie am
boden waren hätte ich auf jeden fall
gesagt die kollekte mir ist es wichtig
da waren sie aber viel an boden und
hatten sie auch keine lust mehr und das
war glaube ich zwei mal die woche was
passiert das ist einfach unkontrolliert
stuhl weg ging und sie haben gesagt so
lohnt sich nicht mehr weiter zu jetzt
wenn ich sie jetzt so sehen würde ich
sagen kann man auf jeden fall noch mal
warten und noch mal weiter versuchen das
unter kontrolle zu bringen und die
entzündungswerte gehen darum das bessert
sich ja auch vom labor es sehen besser
aus und es kann wirklich gut sein dass
die entscheidung für sie einfach druck
weggenommen hat stress reduziert hat
jetzt lassen sie es wieder ein bisschen
laufen lassen bis los und deshalb wir
wissen ja dass solche psychischen
komponenten bei der colitis viel dazu
beitragen wie die entzündung sich
entwickelt kann durchaus sein dass das
jetzt die besserung mit sich bringt da
ist kein sport mehr machen nicht mehr
auf die einigung gucken das gute leben
des tiefen entstand sein ist ja
grundsätzlich nicht schlecht da haben
wir sogar einen job
erleichterung aber nicht nur also muss
sich so vorstellen stoffs 5 meter und
wenn es zum gruppe um die operation zu
machen
es kann so viel passieren in ranzel
mache es kommt mir verhauen und den
wieder alles noch schlimmer
oder der kunde einfach und ich bin jetzt
da jetzt wie das starke leer aber läuft
und seit jahren eigentlich müsste ja
garnicht kumpeln und zu und nicht der
mieter habe
und das findet sich eine gute wenn man
halt nicht gut aber ich hatte riesige
stellt schätzt vor dem sprung und meine
ganze gemacht hätten ist im wahrsten
sinne des wortes
das oberste ziel von mir muss jetzt sie
schiller ist also alles in china was sie
will
manager für gedanken machen antritt und
so hoffen eine remission seinen vorsatz
kann er nicht lange halten
robin hat so viel energie und ideen wie
schon lange nicht mehr und auch gut
es gebe nämlich deutlich besser als noch
vor vier monaten
robin heißt jeder projekte an trifft
freunde ist als dj unterwegs und träumt
sogar einen award für seine radiosendung
ab
also mir gesundheitlich konkurrenz um im
terminkalender um so ist es mir gott
umso voller terminkalender und umgekehrt
und wahrscheinlich dumm aber will man
denn der tibetische typ auf dem waldsee
wo einfach die taxen meditierten zeitig
beginnen und die sie mit allem ist das
erstrebenswert es aus liebe zu ihr ich
sage nein
und jetzt 70 sowie steuer und ich hoffe
nicht dass ich in zwei mal wieder ganz
anders darlegt und sagt hallo ich bin's
ausleben und zu tun
robin kostet die momente aus in denen er
sich gut fühlt
am abend steht ein weihnachtsessen des
vereins menschen mit
autoimmunerkrankungen und handicap mia
in seinem terminkalender
er wird überschwänglich empfangen
in den letzten jahren ist er mit seinem
flug zu deren sprachrohr geworden
am treffen wird über den
gesundheitszustand therapien und
medikamente diskutiert dieser austausch
mit der community ist ihm wichtig ach
gott und ich sah wie gut es mir jetzt
wieder gott sie hat mich aktie was mir
ganz ganz schlecht fangen ist und das
macht er hoffnung
ich sehe das kein zustand für emmerich
dass sie sich immer wieder auf eine
andere positive hoffentlich leiden viele
negative aber das gibt viel nach fch
denn ist so schlag gegangen und jetzt
plötzlich aber das so gut dass komiker
unter sich sein zustand ist verhindert
dass man sich bewusst sind
als hätte er es geahnt zwei wochen nach
diesem geselligen abend schlägt die
krankheit colitis ulcerosa ganz
plötzlich und mit voller wucht zurück
robin bricht unter dem erneuten schub
zusammen
befremdlich angegriffen
was irgendein grund genießen egal
und ich investiere
[Musik]
zu finden
stunde
[Musik]
morgen zieht sich zurück macht auch
keine videos mehr
zu groß sind die schmerzen und die
enttäuschung
er probiert noch ein letztes medikament
aus doch auch das zeigt nicht die
gewünschte wirkung
so fällt ihm der entscheid diesmal
leichter los los hört sich vital und da
sich mein tag 1 verhindere
hinter dicken bildungs operiert sie
steht nach sieben jahren mit der
krankheit und nach alles probieren
womöglich wo sie zum schluss ko und sage
dass gott nicht so ist man im laden
denn einen tag vor der op beschäftigt
ihn etwas sehr
es gibt leute in seiner online-community
die ihm schreiben er habe zu wenig
gekämpft um seinen daumen
er würde aufgegeben hätte dies und jenes
noch nicht ausprobiert
und ich bezweifle und in der gp2
phlegmatisch aber gesund sind und so die
schranke zum schluss gar nicht sehen sie
das ist doch gut an
das ist wirklich dass ich unglaublich
und betroffenen linien erklärten
jugendlicher sagte mir aber meine
krankheit nicht und blieb dann der
ältere zu erklären was im monat und das
nicht so lang sie ist alleine zu tun und
da wird sich jeder rast rafah jeder und
zwar plötzlich doch markt welche
allerdings schlicht wie siehst du aus
erst mal gespielt also habe ich mir
einen bart wachsen lassen
wenn ich morgen als der narkose aufwacht
so bin ich und so werde ich machen um
später welches hier haben wir 2015
[Musik]
verliert den humor auch dann nicht wenn
ihnen die angst im nacken sitzt
jetzt steht er auf dem fünf meter brett
und muss springen
aber es kommt ja gut bei den profis die
besten wird
schwer ins ziel ist dass sie im juni mit
der beratung also im 2 das ist nämlich
anteil mit den linien regierung
[Musik]
april 2009 10
ich besuche rubin am tag nach seiner
operation der haupt herz einer
autoimmunerkrankung der dickdarm wurde
entfernt und ein künstlicher darmausgang
ein sogenanntes thoma angelegt
ich weiß dass jetzt ein langer weg von
bhs wird jetzt zwischen moto bis wieder
stabil
aufsitzen die rehabilitation ist einiges
mühsamer und dauert länger als von robin
erwartet den steinigen weg zur besserung
hält er in seinem video blog fest
ich kann sagen heute der zweite tag nach
der op ist sind wir scheiße noch starke
schmerzen im bauch tag 6 nach der op
[Musik]
ja es gibt ein bisschen besser als
gestern aber noch nicht gut
ja ich poste zu meinem körper ein
bisschen ich möchte laufen laufen laufen
beim siebten achten tag nach der op wenn
es jetzt richtig gruselig und zwar wenn
ich meinen strom wechseln
ihr seht ich zieh dir jemand auch weil
ich das noch nicht so verkraften kann
und jetzt muss ich das wieder anbringen
heute geht es mir schlecht daraus
gestern
ich bin mit 39 5 fieber aufgewacht
nach einem dreiwöchigen reha-aufenthalt
kämpft robin zu hause mit neuen
problemen
die starken medikamente zeigen
nebenwirkungen
ob ja die machen ihn abhängig und
depressive verstimmungen kommen hinzu
so viel müll
ich habe das gefühl mein körper sind im
frack schön manchmal gern so bodies
wappen jemanden sagen komm spring du mal
so eine stunde meinen körper und ich in
deinen da habe ich mal eine stunde pause
und du erlebst was es bedeutet mit all
den kleinen bullshit problemen jeden tag
zu kämpfen
doch mit den wochen heilen die wunden
und die bullshit probleme werden weniger
es ist mitte september fünf monate nach
der operation
zwei männer sind herzlich und auch gar
nicht erforscht wie man sagen dass und
nässe und ich habe neue lebensqualität
und in dem heute das wiederum dank dem
sack und da bringt mir wirklich neue
lebensqualität wo will ich nicht
erwartet hätte
also mich lacht sie und schlimm ist sie
wurden von ihrem funktioniert weil ich
während der fahrt auf dem gummiboot mir
ein halb stuttgart bis auf die ethik
aber an gemüse und die klimakiste sowie
das frische also schrecklich sich also
nicht nur für mich sondern auch für die
verhinderung der auf einem guten weg sie
sind und ich bin so froh dass das jetzt
wieder gott und haben jetzt wieder lust
und eine ganz andere mannschaft ist klar
eben davor war es natürlich schon so mag
immer daran gedacht auch ich gebe mir
jetzt am ort wo er aufs klo kann weil es
könnte ja sein dass er jetzt aufs klo
muss und dann hat er nur sekunden
und wir sollten schon eingeschränkt was
auch mich und ich denke auch den orbit
und er hat jetzt so eine ganz andere art
wie auch wieder quasi agiert von dem er
absolut hat jetzt ist ein anderer mensch
so ein bisschen erhöhen würde also jetzt
wo alle medikamente sind das ist lustig
ich nehme das wäre unvorstellbar ich
brauche drei kreuze sohn ich brauch kein
schmerzmittel ich nicht und ich das
gefühl hatte ich will sb fluss da
einfach
robin träumt von noch mehr
lebensqualität von einem leben ohne
stürmer darum entscheidet er sich für
einen jackpot der zwei weitere
operationen notwendig macht strom ab und
dann gibt es eine verbindung wieder zum
austausch aller kritik bleibt also man
nimmt uns jetzt auch nicht wieder
beziehen und zwar bei der künstlichen
big bang musste visio
am dritten oktober dann die zweite
operation von dreien der körper weiß
aus einem stück dünndarm wird ein
künstliches stuhl reservoir geformt dass
die damen klärung hinauszögern soll bei
der dritten operation wird dieses
reservoir wieder an den auftrag
angeschlossen
[Musik]
dennis möglichkeit dass ich heute wieder
ganz normal ist sehen wir normalos weg
haben und an schienen mehr
lebensqualität und ihre lebensqualität
wenn nicht nur qualität und das sägewerk
also besser mit einem weiterhin später
geht die operation sondern oder total
gemacht
diese und auch die dritte operation im
dezember 2019 verlaufen gut
[Musik]
am tag vor seinem 39
geburtstag kommt robin rehmann als einer
nachkontrolle
er hat sich verliebt und dies mit seiner
freundin zusammengezogen
ohne dick doch alles gut aber so einfach
ist es leider nicht
also ich glaube die idee dass man
einfach wieder gesund wird
ich glaube nicht also wird marita
niemand so verkauft dass ich den text
haben unternehmen und auch ein wenig
sand und hübsches junges reh brise fand
aber ich jetzt mal gerne so vorgestellt
online verkündet er in dieser zeit
überraschend das ende seines colitis
ulcerosa flugs nach 250 videos ich bin
mir nicht nach plan koffer komische
wunder da jetzt ein buch das noch einmal
zeigen
da der mist sagen funktioniere nicht
richtig und nur theater und seine pleite
schon alle videos machen ohne kamera ja
mal anzeigt und schlagt uns funktioniert
nicht aber was ist was ich da was hilft
smi neigen ihre eigene bemitleidet ich
werde ja glück motiviert bist andere
situation es ist scheiße aber es ist
definitiv nicht so schön aber ebenso
erforderlich wie die eigen machen eine
extrem sportart weiß nicht was du machst
einfach krank und ja irgendwann auch das
loch nicht aber einige haben es möglich
wenn wir das sieht den mac hersteller
wie geil sich eine funktionierende
körper zu haben nämlich völlig auf
seinen verstand rede meint das menü
gemacht und ich einfach geschickter und
verlocken buch aber das ist völlig
normal und man im regen war entsprechend
groß
tobi ist es nicht selbstverständlich
dass alles gut funktioniert
unglaublich wenn wir so eine krankheit
wie ich sie jetzt hat dann schätzt mehr
gesundheit für filme und man ist wenn es
normal ist wenn einfach alles gut ist
hinter und glücklich und ich kann mich
noch erinnere mich nur gesund sie
wenigstens los zeichen und ich einfach
was mir einfach körperlich gar nicht
dass sie nicht lang im körper der
besonders durch den kopf
haben wir auch nicht wohl gefühlt jetzt
langt's durch gar nicht mehr glücklich
unseres clubs krieg nicht mehr erreicht
und ich glaube es braucht ein schmerz
und gehört hinter dem schmerz ist glück
und wenn wir den schmerz nicht das
gibt's gar nicht
johanni zu hoch ein halbes jahr später
im august 20 20 besserung ist willkommen
so das anliegen sms silence das ist dies
eine sache wo viele ich nicke 33 prozent
wir werden auch über die eigene
immobilie in moderiert wieder
es geht ihm gut was man dann trotzdem
ein normales leben wie vor dem ausbruch
der krankheit wird er nie mehr haben
nicht lange wanderung gemacht oder und
legen ihre spaziergang also ich muß
schon immer sitzer und pause machen und
legen sich meine energie benannt
auch hat er immer noch sechs bis acht
stuhl gänge pro tag nachts muss er
deswegen auf stehen die
autoimmunerkrankung colitis ulcerosa ist
unheilbar
sie kann sich jedoch durch die
entfernung des dickdarms nicht mehr in
ihrer vehemenz zeigen
ich bereue operation auf keinen fall
bevor wie es gemacht
symptomatisch sicher besser es ist ein
richtig heft die geschichte sieht also
ich mache gerade so spontan einfach also
lebensrhythmus möglich hoch sieht dass
man sich auf der silos und die stadt
sehr schwierig zu sagen dass peter ag
tätig ist das land wieder ins grimma mit
und die krankheit hat einfach einen
großen teil hausgemacht und die werden
immer mitschwingen
aber ich hoffe dass sie jetzt die
nächste um die hauptrolle hat wie die
letzten zwei jahre
ich glaube tragen man sich wirklich
vorstellen
aber wenn sie denn mal deutsch mal schon
wieder witze lachen übrig hinter sollen
die diagnose chronisch krank bedeutet
für immer aber bei robin steht die
krankheit heute nicht mehr im
mittelpunkt seines lebens
[Musik]